Let's put it all together and see how Android file system
enables authorized users who are members of
a campus community to log in remotely from work station over
insecure links and use private key crypto system to
validate the users. And allow them to get useful work done on
the work station. They login using the username and password.
They get back a pair of tokens a secret token and clear token, and this
is the first communication that happens between venus and vize. Venus
can then establish an RPC session on behalf of the client by using the secret
token and HKC. That's the second class of communication that happens between
Venus and Vice, and as a result of this session establishment.
What Venus gets back is a session key for use in this particular
RPC session. Subsequently, any time the user opens a file,
or closes a file, or writes to a file, all those file system
calls. That requires Venus to communicate with vice,
is going to be sent as secure RPC using the secret token
as a client ID and SK, the session
key, as the private key for encrypting the message that it wants to send.
To vice, and similarly vice is going to
send back responses uses the session key. So
this is a third class of client server
interaction that I mentioned. So there are three
classes of client server interaction. The first one is login, second
one is RPC session establishment, and the third one is the
actual. Secure RPC calls that are being made for manipulating
the files sytem that resides in the central server. So the upshot of
this structure that Andrew Files System provides for the user community is
that the user name and password is exposed only once per login
session. So in other words if a student logs in to a work
station once or twice a day, it's only that many
number of times that the user name and passwords are going to be used on this
insecure network. The hand shake key that Venus gets back as a result of setting
up a login session for a user is used only for new RPC sessions. That's a second
class of communication. And the validity of this hand shake key is the duration
of the login session. You know that passwords have a long ability deed as valid
as long as you don't change your password but, the duration of this HKC that
is used for RPC session establishment, that
is only for the duration of the login
session. Once the user has logged off and
left this work station. A secret token and
a clear token are thrown away by Venus, so the duration of the HKC is only for
this login session. And a session key is used for all the RPC calls that
Venus is making on behalf of this client
from manipulating the file system. And the duration
of SK is the duration of a given
RPC session. For instance, within one log in session,
let's say, I have three different RPC
sessions. For each of those distinct RPC sessions,
I'm going to get a unique session key. And
I'm going to use that session key only for
that particular RPC session. Once that is
done, I cannot re-use that key anymore. I'll
have to re-establish a new RPC session, and
get a new session key, and restart the
RPC session. So in this lesson, module as a whole. First, we
looked at taxonomies proposed by Solser, and then, we saw
how we can build a practical system, which
can be used by a campus community for securely
accessing information. In this case. Files stored in a central
repository through the Andrew file system. Now, it is time
for a question that is really asking you to think
about the Andrew file system and its strengths and weaknesses
with respect to providing security guarantees for the user community.